so are you gonna follow the rules
or are you gonna follow
your instincts
i'm not sure it matters because either
way we are descending into madness with
this one
[Music]
all right let me say up front this video
ultimately is just for me i have no clue
if anybody else cares or is curious
about the 1992 box office bomb that is
cool world but i have been fascinated by
it for 30 years now
i actually don't remember when i first
saw it all the way through it wasn't in
the theater and i guess it was
probably video rental 94 maybe 95.
before i committed to this video i
hadn't rewatched it since whenever i
watched it the first time
yet
i remembered way more of this film than
i should and the trailer's been burned
into my memory for quite a while
[Music]
i'm more than overdue to unravel this
tangled web of misguided development
chaotic shooting and bizarre final film
that resulted from it so let's talk
about it
cool world is an animation and
live-action hybrid film held by cult
animation director and possible madman
ralph bakshi it cost 20 million dollars
to make and broaden returns of just over
half that critics absolutely savaged it
here was a movie where you could often
see the seams and they were not
particularly convincing oh absolutely
you could see the seams and it currently
holds a
four percent on rotten tomatoes it was
called a one joke movie two series to be
fun too goofy to take seriously
surprisingly incompetent and a roger
corman version of roger rabbit
now
i should be clear about my intentions
here
i'm not here to defend this film because
it's most certainly not some critically
misunderstood gem with hidden depths
that weren't appreciated at the time i'm
not sure i'd even say it's so bad that
it's good like how one might describe
something like the room or the happening
what no
but
i still want to pull it apart
because it fails in ways that are
bizarre and unique and worth examining
and we're trying to figure out why did
that happen
but before we can really get into this
there is one major complication that
needs to be addressed when it comes to
talking about this movie more
particularly when talking about the
making of it because it was made prior
to the rise of internet movie culture
things like what i do
and in fact it actually came out at a
time when many households didn't even
have internet access so there wasn't
much that was documented or archived
about the making of this film dvds
wouldn't be around for a few more years
so
if there ever was much in the way of
behind the scenes documentation of the
making of
there really wasn't much reason to keep
it because there were no extras on vhs
tapes and it wasn't a liked movie so it
wasn't like they were going to get a tv
special on how it was made
because it was such a notorious bomb
very few people involved in the film at
any level appear to ever want to talk
about it even to this day
the one person who is more than happy to
talk about it is director ralph bakshi
now the thing is under normal
circumstances that might be enough to go
with in terms of trying to figure out
how this film ended up the way it did
in this case
it's kind of a problem because bakshi
has
a long established reputation for
let's go with flamboyant exaggeration
for example when talking about the
making of his animated lord of the rings
film bakshi has claimed that he had
3 000 people in the studio back in new
york animating when realistically it
would have been around maybe
but that's why i say prone to
exaggeration instead of lying because
when you drill down into bakshi's
various wild claims that he's let loose
over the decade you can usually find an
original nugget of truth that has been
distorted in the telling and the
retelling sometimes to frankly comical
degrees
that's why trying to find out what
really happened in the development and
shooting of this film is so difficult
because if you were to say look at the
wikipedia entry on it the source for
most of the claims which aren't really
challenged
they come from interviews with bakshi
himself
and virtually no corroboration or
secondary sources on most of these
things it probably doesn't help that
since the release of cool world actually
has been various degrees of retired he's
popped up now and then with smaller
productions almost entirely outside of
the major forces in hollywood he worked
briefly with hbo on a series called
spicy city in 97 but when the network
wanted to replace his in-house writing
staff with hollywood writers for a
second season bakshi flatly refused and
he really hasn't touched anything close
to a major studio or network production
since
in other words
he has no reason to be polite or rein in
his exaggerations because he doesn't
have to worry about maintaining good
relationships with anybody in the
industry
now honestly
i'm not sure the man ever gave a single
solitary [ __ ]
but if he did he's had no reason to hold
on to it for the last 25 years
the upshot of this is that
i'm honestly pretty doubtful about a
fair amount of the information i'm going
to be sharing with you about the
development and production of this movie
there is ultimately going to be a bit
more speculation on my part than i'm
normally comfortable doing
largely just by my trying to figure out
what that original nugget of truth is
underneath all of bakshi's
bonkers claims
ultimately
most of these are going to be guesses on
my part
but they have to be
because that's all i've got
so with the preamble out of the way
what even is cool world
cool world starts out with a painfully
generic opening credit sequence that
practically screams we had no money left
by the time we got to this part and it
then launches into what is effectively a
prologue scene in 1945 where the
character frank harris played by a not
yet broken through stardom brad pitt
returns from serving in world war ii and
decides to celebrate by taking his
mother for a joy ride on a motorcycle
they get into an accident his mother
dies and frank is transported to the
cartoon cool world thanks to an
invention called the spike created by a
cartoon scientist called doc whiskers
this is probably the point where i
should warn you to not look for much
logic behind most of what i'm going to
be telling you because if there ever was
any
it got buried under nonsense
along the way events jump ahead to then
present day 1992 where jack deebs played
by gabriel byrne is in prison for
murdering a man he caught sleeping with
his wife
deebs has been passing his time in
prison drawing various characters and
aspects of cool world which are being
published as a comic book while he
finishes out his sentence oh and just in
case you're wondering how things like
frank being a world war ii veteran or
his mother dying or jack's history of
violence factor into the story
uh they don't
like
at all
at a guess
maybe the reason for frank to come from
the 1940s might be there to serve as
kind of an in-universe explanation for
him behaving like an outdated grizzled
noir stock character
so if that's the case it's odd that the
film felt the need to give context to
that when there's so little context for
most of what else goes on in it and even
if you feel that works the film loses
almost
10 minutes on introducing frank with his
barely relevant backstory so it's a
misplaced priority at best and as for
jack being in jail at the start i
honestly can't think of a single reason
why that's there
his history never really factors into
things and the idea that he's violently
jealous could have come up with later
stuff very easily but it just
doesn't
at a guess it's an aspect that probably
mattered in an earlier draft but the
reasons for having it eventually were no
longer there and the backstory stuck
around despite no longer being useful
like like an appendix or a vestigial
tale
anyways for the last decade in prison
jack's been having visions of cool world
and the people in it with a particular
focus on one
holly wood voiced and later on in the
film portrayed in the flesh by kim
basinger soon after jack is released
from prison he gets pulled into the cool
world this is where we learn that frank
is serving as a cop there along with his
inept partner niles who's a spider
because why not their primary job is to
prevent noids which is a slang term for
humans from having sex with doodles the
cartoon denizens of cool world
naturally there is an inherent conflict
here since holly
really wants to get it on with the noid
because
well because that's the that's the plot
of the movie
i've kind of had canon at this point
that holly is a like a dedicated
hedonist who's gone through whatever
pleasure there is to be had in the cool
world and craves new
real experiences
that's not really in the text but that's
what makes sense in my head
naturally jack's an easy target since
he's been lusting after her ever since
he first got a visions of her and
started drawing her so of course
they get it on and somehow this turns
holly human and she escapes to the real
world with jack but her transformation
is unstable and both she and jack start
to flash back and forth between noid and
doodle forms holly goes on a search for
the spike that caused the original tear
between the two worlds which she
believes was brought over to the real
world by a doodle decades ago actually
turns out
that she was right and she runs into a
disguise doc whiskers learns that the
spike is placed atop a hotel believing
it'll stabilize her real flesh form she
goes after it by now frank has realized
what's happened and is in the real world
teaming up with jack to try and stop her
holly knocks frank off a building to his
death and takes control of the spike but
instead of stabilizing her form
it instead allows the cool world to pour
into the real world and start
transforming it into just cartoon
madness
despite this being
nearly the exact opposite of what holly
has wanted up to this point
she appears to be supervillain levels of
gleeful about all this jack gets turned
into a cartoon superhero and after a few
minutes of
just chaos he returns the spy to the
cool world which pulls back all the
doodles undoes the damage and plugs up
the tear between universes frank's body
is also returned to the cool world where
we suddenly learn that if annoyed is
killed by a doodle they become a doodle
for some
reason
well the reason is that this gives frank
a happy ending as he's finally able to
get close to his doodle love interest he
could never get freaky with before and
who i forgot to bring up in all the
chaos of this
it also kind of makes the question why
he didn't just have some doodle kill him
years ago since he stays plainly earlier
in the film that he never wants to go
back to the real world anyways but
whatever
we're just about done it wraps up with
one quick scene of jack and holly
together him a blissful idiot and her
utterly miserable roll the credits
now along the way in all this we have
the constant clash of cartoon violence
with disturbing settings and wooden live
action performances from actors who seem
very lost every now and then the
clashing elements fit together in fun
[Music]
but such moments are countered by
weirdness that doesn't seem to have any
purpose
not even its own sake and sections that
also go on much longer than they can
support the entire bit where holly is in
vegas is the worst of this now at a more
felt run time of say
90 minutes it could have kept up the
pace enough for the chaos to just be
a mad cap roller coaster that
occasionally flings riders off in random
directions but
at 102 minutes it drags in the back end
right up until a brick is put on the
accelerator and it careens off a cliff
so how the heck did this happen
here we get into trying to sort out the
behind the scenes so let's start with
what's pretty safely assumed to be true
in 1990 after ralph bakshi approached
paramount studios which was an
organization he had ties to from his
time in their long defunct in-house
animation studio he went and he pitched
an animation live-action hybrid called
cool world which the studio jumped on
almost certainly because of the runaway
success of who framed roger rabbit two
years prior now bakshi himself had
wanted to try something like this a
while ago decades actually back in the
70s the original intention for his film
hey good looking was to have animated
characters and live action actors
interact
however the film proved too difficult
and costly to be completed as originally
intended ultimately being released in 82
as a wholly animated production now at
the point that he approached paramount
bakshi himself hadn't made a theatrical
film since 1983's fire and ice which is
a movie that i actually would say is so
bad it's good it's immensely riffable
pour some drinks see it with friends but
since 83 he'd only done a handful of tv
specials in shorts such as the
underappreciated adaptation of dr
seuss's similarly under-appreciated the
butter battle book soos himself said it
was the most faithful adaptation of his
work out of all the tv specials that had
been done in his lifetime
but the point is
back she hadn't worked on anything of
notable scale in
quite a while and cool world was hugely
ambitious even with roger rabbit having
already proven the commercial viability
of mixing animation in live action
so what was bakshi's actual story pitch
well here's where things start getting
murky because even in a rush to copy the
success of roger rabbit with an
animation veteran at the helm i have a
hard time imagining paramount going with
what black she currently claims was his
original pitch
bakshi has said his initial plan was for
an animated horror film with the primary
focus on a half reel half cartoon
offspring of a cartoonist in a drawing
who would grow to resent their human
father and attempt to kill him according
to bakshi while he was off working on
pre-production and set building the
producer one frank mancuso jr brought in
new writers on the script and when back
she showed up on the first day of actual
production he was handed a completely
different script from the one he had
been prepping for back she claims to
have actually punched mancuso jr in the
mouth over this
i had a huge fight with the guy and
punched mancuso junior in the mouth
makes for a good story
but this whole
writing of a supposedly new script is
one of the few points that we have some
degree of secondary sourcing on as
michael grace one of the credited
screenwriters gave an interview with
slash film a few years ago and he gave
his side of the story now according to
grace he and his writing partner at the
time mark victor were contacted by
mancuso jr and brought in because
back she had come to paramount with the
concept of an animated live-action
hybrid horror film but no actual plot or
story pitch to speak of
grace said that when he and victor came
up with the core story of a cartoonist
pulled into a cartoon world
that back she was more than happy with
that concept
as for the punching the producer well i
mean there was undoubtedly tension
during production and issues with the
direction of the film and it's safe to
say that bakshi and mancuso jr clashed
at some points
uh
i'm disinclined to believe changes were
suddenly sprung on bakshi out of nowhere
or that it ever came to blows even with
scattered information on behind the
scenes situation there's plenty of
telltale signs in the film itself that
things were changing as it was happening
to some degree just probably not as
drastically as bakshi is claiming
probably the biggest tell is the
backgrounds and landscapes of cool world
which are dark twisted disturbing and
highly detailed they feel very much like
something done early into production
when the film was intended to be more
adult and horror themed but as the film
lurched forward and moved away from
horror into a cartoonishly sexualized
pg-13 there was neither the time nor the
money to redo all the backgrounds and so
they just
stayed there looming over everything as
a marker of some earlier intention
or at least that would certainly explain
why the backgrounds don't really fit
with anything else going on
one of the interesting quirks of the
film is that it starts out with a
slightly odd but largely understandable
premise and gets stranger and stranger
as it goes along the conclusion in
particular feels like an unraveling of
logic to the point that one could be
forgiven if they thought that descending
into madness was actually the overriding
intent of the film
that is however
extremely doubtful as another of the
better verified aspects of the
production is that grace and victor were
having a difficult time cracking the
ending to use grace's own words we
couldn't figure out how this [ __ ]
thing ended
so mancuso junior brought in larry gross
best known at the time for the film's 48
hours and its sequel and he tried to
handle the third act so odds are that
the complete chaos of the last 15
minutes or so are a result of trying to
cap off a production that was probably
very loose and chaotic from the word go
bakshi
has a pretty well earned reputation as
an animation director for not caring
that much about consistency as someone
who'd worked his way up from bottom
level grunt work at age 18 he reveled in
letting his animators stretch their
wings and giving shots to people with
limited experience i hired guys who were
just workmen whom didn't think they were
great that's certainly laudable in its
way
but it does mean that it's not uncommon
in his films for things to shift
stylistically from scene to scene or for
characters to appear like they're from
completely different productions
sometimes this works like in his early
slice of city living films like heavy
traffic where the mixture of visual
style and quality feels reflective of
the crowded urban setting and story
being set in a city that is just as
chaotic and mismatched as the animation
styles however
that same element feels more out of
place in anything trying to tell an
actual coherent overarching or
thematically resonant story
cool world suffers from back cheese
everybody gets a shot and go ahead just
try whatever you want approach in a few
odd ways for instance the idea of an
animator just doing
some weird thing and it didn't have a
place in the film but actually wanted to
throw it in anyways the only explanation
i can think of for something like this
or this
most prominently though there's a very
distinct style disconnect between
hollywood and
basically everything else
this one might have actually been on
purpose since holly and to a lesser
extent frank's girlfriend lynette aren't
meant to be appealing in a pin-up sort
of way
and i should be clear about this holly
is honestly stunningly animated and not
just from a voyeuristic male gaze
perspective although
yeah there is that my point is though
that her movement is smooth appealing
she stands out from the chaos as she
should
but when we get to the climax and
everything goes crazy the whole thing
suddenly feels reminiscent of some of
the more visually disjointed moments in
some of baxter's other films like
wizards where back she himself said that
he just told his animators to draw
mutant doing something funny and he
would just slap whatever they did into
the film
mixed up in this is the bizarre fact
that when holly flashes back and forth
between noid and doodle forms
she's not flashing into holly but like a
clown
and at the end when the spike gets put
back this happens despite her never
having had that level of cartoonishness
before heck her mouth doesn't even move
during some of her lines at the climax
which an animation especially is a
definite sign of things either being
rushed or changed late into production
so the ending feels less like a
deliberate choice to become nonsensical
than it does a handful of creatives
throwing their hands up and saying i
don't know you figure it out to each
other i haven't really talked about the
integration of the animation and the
live action and while it was undoubtedly
a massive technical hurdle it didn't
automatically have to be a big stumbling
block even setting aside back she's
aborted attempt with the affirmation hey
good looking bakshi had been working
with live actors to varying degrees for
decades he'd become partial to
rotoscoping and reference footage in the
late 70s through the early 80s so on
paper this shouldn't have been that much
of a leap
except it very clearly was
and this is where we need to bring in
the inevitable comparison to roger
rabbit because with that film there's a
reason that the film's director
was not also the head of the animation
department robert zemeckis put a great
deal of faith into animation director
richard williams but he also understood
that it was his job to make things as
smooth and possible for williams to work
with this is why the raw footage of
roger rabbit before the animation
overlay is rife with special effects
artists puppeteering objects as well as
the use of motion control cameras to
ensure that shots moved in the exact
same way for every take so that the
animation never appeared to jump out of
place or fail to move with the camera
the way that a filmed object would while
i can't find out a ton of reliable
information on the filming process of
cool world
just the fact that it had little more
than half the budget of roger rabbit
that would indicate there wasn't the
time or the resources to recreate the
same kind of meticulous production
if bakshi would even have wanted to do
it that way
and given his usual work style i'd say
that's
a long shot
one telltale sign of less resources is
the fact that in the cool world much of
the sets that the actors interact with
are 2d props and backdrops probably to
ensure that they only had to do blue
screen compositing when absolutely
necessary and that's fine to be using
these flats as far as a cost cutting
measure goes except that the camera
moves in such a way as to draw attention
to the fact that many of the sets are
literally just painted flats there's
even some truly weird things like
frank's car which flips between being
fully animated a real practical car and
a flat 2d standee of a car from shot to
shot
there's also a stiffness to the actors
performances probably owing to how much
they were either standing on empty sets
or against blue screen backdrops now
blue screen or green screen more used
now it's a very common practice today as
pretty much any movie with a budget of
over 70 million dollars has got to
involve the actors acting in with or
against
nothing but in the early 90s
most actors didn't really know how to
make that work simply because they
hadn't had to do it before it wasn't
normal
and it probably didn't help that of all
the things that have been said about
bakshi positive and negative nobody's
ever described him as an actor's
director speaking of the actors that's
another area where bakshi said some
things that are
tricky to parse with reality but she
claims he never wanted basinger in the
role he said in interviews conducted in
the years since that he wanted drew
barrymore which
is a curious claim given that at the
time of filming she would have been 15
or 16 years old the idea of a minor
playing holly is
unsettling
now to give at least the option for
benefit of the doubt it's possible that
what he really meant was he wanted
barrymore to play whatever the original
concept for holly was possibly even
meaning he wanted her to be the
half-human half-cartoon murderer he
originally had in his initial pitch
assuming that there is validity to that
that at least would track a little bit
better as barrymore had started dipping
into horde not long after her breakout
in et back in 82
but again it's hard to know how much
stock to put into what back she claims
was his original pitch in the first
place so
who even knows
but even setting that aside
bakshi's words toward basinger seem to
indicate the two did not exactly gel on
set
back she claims that she wanted to tone
the movie down stating
kim wanted a pg film to show in hospital
so she could get a good reputation
what does that even mean
movies don't get screened in hospitals
if they want something for patients to
see they just turn on the tv but even
beyond that saying that she needed a
good reputation is a that's a weird
claim too
like at the time this film was released
basically was easily the biggest star
out of the three leads and while it's
true she first got big with more risque
material like nine and a half weeks she
was in batman in 1989 which as dark as
it was was largely considered to be a
family film
she didn't need a reputation boost
but as per usual there's probably a
crumb of truth in there somewhere if we
dig
bakshi probably always wanted to make an
r-rated film that seems safe to assume
if for no other reason than adult
material was his comfort zone even the
man's family film
family film wizards which i have a soft
spot for but
has a lot of problems that movie
features graphic violence and nazi
imagery and it seems like there was
definitely tension between bakshi and
the studio about how far he could push
this since paramount as best as i could
find always wanted this to have a pg-13
rating at most and if bakshi was pushing
the boundaries or at least trying to and
basinger was among the voices trying to
reel him in well
that seems like it could be the much
more believable crumb of truth
underneath the
pg film to show in hospitals claim
kim i think that's wonderful
but you've got the wrong guy to do that
with
it's worth remembering that in 1992
pg-13 rating was still relatively new it
got introduced in 86 but the general
sense of what was allowed was starting
to solidify by this point
and cool world was definitely pushing at
the limits
with its basic concept alone i mean the
entire central conceit is based around
not only two characters having sex
despite explicit warnings not to and in
the case of one of them wanting to do it
for selfish and borderline nefarious
reasons but it also talks openly about
the fact that that's what's going on and
honestly having now re-watched it i'm
less surprised that the concept squeaked
through with the pg-13 than i am at the
fact that it did so while being devoid
of subtext
do not have sex with doodles
just as a quick comparison roger rabbit
coded sexual innuendo with allusions to
things like playing patty cake but cool
world
they just say it
noids do not have sex with doodles this
kind of naked acknowledgement of adult
lust didn't really happen in pg-13
movies though the fact that one of the
two characters in question is animated
might have been what helped to secure
that rating but regardless i have little
doubt that bakshi wanted to do much more
than he was ultimately permitted to do
and keep in mind he was permitted to
include shots like
these
[Music]
and given all that i would not be
shocked if basinger at some point in the
process expressed some concerns about
the direction but i genuinely have a
hard time believing she wanted to turn
it into a pg film
i think she knew at least generally what
she signed on for at least as much as
anybody involved did
but the reality is we'll probably never
know for sure what went on in the
development shooting or even the
animation process of cool world that
resulted in this absolutely bizarre film
because the simple truth is that nearly
everybody involved wants to pretend like
it never happened and the only one
willing to talk is probably the single
least reliable source available so what
does that leave us in trying to
understand this thing
well
it leaves us with a deeply bizarre film
that is probably not really worth seeing
for anybody other than those with an
interest in failed oddities but
for whatever reason it's something my
brain has never been able to shake for
the last 30 years
whether that means it did something
right
or did something so wrong that it's
impossible to forget
well i guess you'd have to see it for
yourself to judge
if you don't mind feeling like a drunk
animation buff is screaming directly
into your brain for about 100 minutes
but that's cool world
it is
something else and i have a number of
kind of
i'm not sure how deep a dive this was
but these sorts of examinations of
things that are intriguing to me that
i've wanted to do for a bit
and i actually put it up as a poll on my
patreon you can support me there and get
to vote in polls like this where i ask
people i didn't tell them what movies i
was or what movies or tv shows i was
thinking of like okay do you want me to
rip into something do you want me to
praise something that i think doesn't
get enough attention or do you want me
to examine something that's just weird
they voted for the weird and you get
cool world
so any help you can give on the patreon
is of immense support it's what allows
me to do this as my living and have a
new video up for you every single
saturday
but even if you can't do that
like share subscribe also help
and more than anything whatever your
thoughts on this movie are drop them
down in the comments let's talk about it
i want to hear if anybody else remembers
this thing or if hearing me talk about
it encourages people to check it out for
themselves i want to hear what your
experience was
but but the thing that i really want you
to remember more than anything
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned just remember
noids do not have sex with doodles
goddess this is so weird
[Music]
time to give my thanks to my highest
supporting patrons that would include
robin moore zubin ludwig to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime
oliver b melinda walters imudelki
theotha boyd becky sparks bernaby likes
the poodle zach idolin tracy scrabbit
angry casper adam rdl taylor shane ross
shaylee gourley brendan larose and tt
[Music]
if you want your name said while these
guys try and distract me
consider looking at the rewards of my
patreon
[Music]
um
[Music]